boobs I ever welcome a table I'm like my
hardy and this is roofie poop-poop I got
her good she didn't see me do it
that's Marrakech it's really good when
you do it because you don't mix up the
names oh yeah yeah so that's a back with
Reza navel the show that's been around
for far too long all right I got some we
got some well we should be an
interesting episode today for happy
joining us we're like fun today I'm
going to release this awesome photo I
received of you of me yeah have you been
talking to Dan Reicher or Tim Terry that
Dan this is not going well there you go
yeah sweet I'm glad you shared that that
was from a wedding in Minneapolis that
was at the game informer office the the
night before the wedding we all hung out
there that was last year I mean that was
a long time ago no that was last year so
[Music]
who gave that to you I have little birds
all over it the only person people I
know with it are Dan Reicher and Tim
Terry and you don't know anybody else
that was at that wedding or Ben Hansen
maybe all right whatever sweet
so we got the water motif key I'm trying
to move on past the photo I spilled beer
on my crotch I've got the water motif
you got them water motif Roman crotch
and we also so that's what we're doing
next time sweetie okay sweet Mike you
forgot to give me my mic so obviously
the hunters you got D okay what did you
get from that hunter room the tablet one
of the tablets no you're the key okay
cool so you got the water motif key from
there if you kill a few hunters you
didn't take any harm it went pretty well
I killed both hunters with no problems
but I did die to a spide on purpose
because I didn't do very good so don't
forget to wipe forget to why that's our
suite yeah so now we got the water motif
key it is back upstairs I would
recommend what nothing I was gonna ask
should I go to the main hall because I
have like grenades and all this stuff I
don't know if I need it all but I'm
actually not sure it upstairs I don't
think you're coming back into the base
do you know how to get back upstairs the
most efficient way because I'm not sure
no oh you killed all the monkeys right
so yeah you did go back you only have
one choice I think to go back up cuz
that room on the left goes to where
Rebecca was you gotta go yeah but wait
items on the ground
Magnum rounds and I don't have a Magnum
but you're not coming back down here so
I think you should bring them in a puck
yeah I think do you have room for both
of them
no maybe come back let me look first if
you need pucks we can just come back
down later I'm pretty sure I don't but I
can look real fast because I was messing
with it okay
all right she's got one space he's got
none space so we're taking the magnum
rounds just to have him upstairs okay
pick him up baby people were mentioning
that we should go back to that chemical
thing we were about to get something no
I heard about this
she's the chemical lady he's not a
chemical man so if there's chemicals we
should interact with it with her and if
it's tattoo related we should interact
with it with him yes that makes more
sense
[Music]
sorry I'm just looking through four can
you go so yeah you cleared out the
monkeys I forgot to eliminate Apes not
monkeys got him alright so we're going
back to the main howl thanks for the
birthday wishes last week you see my
other deck I wrote and Marian Mike
burned down a forest perfectly innocent
woodland creatures also shocking a few
monkeys they had it coming just
descriptive as I got man again isn't it
this way no that's where that's where
she was hanging it's the other one is it
this stairs yeah come with me
oh he's hurt I could totally be wrong I
mean oh no it isn't the one you were
just that I think this is the creep this
is the way you got that I thought it was
because these go to here right where do
these go to all right but I don't know
because I'm dumb so also someone said at
the end of in one of those rooms there
actually is an item when I said it was a
waste of ammo or whatever are you
talking about this room yeah or one of
these the one of the this is the one I
think they said something's I'm supposed
to be under a bed and I'm also full but
I'd like to just see and I've already
killed all the zombies in here so so
check under a bed
maybe that one on the far right
maybe someone's messing with us
it could be just trolling us cuz leak
yeah it's such a pain there's like
nothing if there's something in this
room it's really well-hidden and I don't
want to hear any more about the sparse
sheets to the stairs what is today the
9th when it airs almost October [ __ ]
happy Halloween yeah do you know you're
being for Halloween yet uh we should do
something for the show well I already
did mine do you want to like join in now
I'll be Billy why is this so hard for me
I'll try to do my hair like Billy's as
much as I can I like this I think it is
those stairs to your right the ones that
I was at and you said it wasn't them no
I said it was and I was like maybe not
so I'm confused so these are no so not
this try it hey might as well you know
this is where she was hanging from or
this is the right ones the classic issue
I mean I'm happy to dress up again oh
okay good then I'm happy to dress up as
her again oh there's a plant or we could
we could tease our next series I'm
kidding that's a joke we got plenty of
resonable game we got so many Resident
Evil's I can't wait no eerily
revelations is very good there's no need
to go down this path because there's so
much stuff to talk like so much stuff to
play already yeah I'm happy to do that I
was also thinking I'm working with a
couple girls on an idea but we're like
it's still in the making process for
Halloween yeah the kind when I when I
say making process I mean like it's at
that point where we could still abandon
the idea like
good ideas yes commit probably not like
worth mentioning until it's like yeah we
doing it and then I can like okay I vote
some stuff here before you okay so what
kind I like
probably not gonna have another boss buy
it based on a few comments I have it on
good authority that a Molotov will be
useful
okay grenades no I don't think so okay
while you're figuring this out interrupt
me if you need my help but Nathan
Shepard as always doing the Lord's work
that you guys have switched between
billion okay actually Mary do not look
keep looking at your time will not how
many times do you think you've switched
between Billy and Rebecca are you talk
about just like when I do this cuz it's
a lot ok I'm flabbergasted that Nathan
counted this but like no maybe not in
the the maybe not in the inventory but
when I play as a character I've done it
a lot okay about how many times okay a
hundred and ten two hundred over two
hundred times now so maybe he's not
coming I don't think so I'm three deaths
but again one was a wipe but it still
counts seventy six kills one of which
was a stinger which one was that oh the
scorpion was it a scorpion we
established yeah yeah and I thought it
was something 311 think he's gonna want
a shotgun and the grenade launchers on
alignment probably yeah that seems
reasonable right though air you're about
to go do is pretty close quarters the
green launchers on board with its first
two kills cool thank you so much Nathan
we appreciate it we'll see you next week
hi this week nice to see you
res fantasy fans at tip time to prevent
unnecessary backtracking later in the
game take the items from the main hall
to the observatory room especially the
hookshot
the observatory room is the one off the
wet room that's circular one I believe
if memory serves I could be wrong
oh is that gonna be like my new hub soon
yeah I think so if that's this is to be
believed is this a good shotgun pretty
sure it is yes the other the one
together and still in the dining room
[ __ ] marry idiot and then also res
fantasy fan was clarifying a few the
things I was trying to remember about
revelations 1 & 2 bless you revelations
2 features Claire Redfield with Moira
Burton and then Barry Burton with
Natalia groan sherry Birkin sherry
Birkin is in res evil six with Jake
Wesker and then thank you for the
birthday wish what are my thoughts in
the resonable to remake footage from TGS
I watched it briefly it was a ttle open
your map it's nearer you got the grenade
launcher so up I think yeah it's bad
back I'm pretty sure that red one is the
water door okay so we're gonna go up
stairs and to the right you're gonna see
some enemies I don't know how much I
didn't see how many healing items you
have on hand I have a full heal for him
and I have nothing for her
what do you think how do I bring more I
certainly don't want them to die but I
think you're fine also for these types
of situations is having him on auto
still like the right thing to do here
like auto fire yeah I believe I have him
on oh I think for this situation coming
up should make a model really I mean I
don't know I mean I'm sure you feel more
comfortable with attack on but I don't
know your mo is not like super plentiful
I just don't like I'm doing nothing
yeah okay just sitting there I mean you
can look like pretty if you run into a
situation you can just pause really
quickly in turn okay Liam Smith a
constant viewer you will never be right
about our III Mike I still love you
though I love you no wait what we sing
no I remember I was just saying I can't
be someone's favorite in the series Oh
I'm just being a love what you love
thank you ma'am
what's that noise was that always that
noise
do they know he's always occur before
you go toward the water door can you go
to the opposite side Ramona yeah so
that's the observatory someone was
mentioned so you want me to go to the
observatory
no no that's that's what res fantasy fan
had mentioned to make the new hub soon
right so maybe that leads to the
treatment plan or whatever no this is
the training facility yeah treatment
plan oh no I was just curious if that's
not a water to pass the water oh yeah oh
I went the wrong way then yeah you gotta
go but what's in the I don't ever get
the lay of the land treatment facility
then I don't know just the next area
like training facility basement train oh
and then I've been calling it's in here
I've been calling this viewer ocean it's
a sheen machine if I've been to know I
gotta love my weird Irish name I love it
my middle name is Rohan are you a any I
didn't you didn't know that no that my
mom's maiden name Rohan
it's it looks like Ruane we just savory
Wayne but it's Rulon mine's Elizabeth
yeah pronounced Elizabeth full name is
Michael Ranma Hardy and it's uh
supposedly in like old Irish Gaelic it
means family they're redheads thanks
Mike happy birthday you were going to
tell us the details about a potential
Silent Hill series I think the fans
would love it when rosie was done as
always we're gonna play that as it wise
and see what happens I France evil but
we got a whole few more games and then
res Newell to like I said all right here
we go what's in that room I mean
are you asking the room I'm in right now
it's a hallway and it goes to the left
the one right next to you looks like
something you should go in the one to
the ribs yeah okay well I feel like I'm
here oh that's a leech that's what I'm
all topping what's a leech the Molotov
bang yeah
yeah yeah it's go through that door well
he's got to die right I'm honestly not
sure they transform at some point but
the fire is yeah what am i doing fire
again
fire again yeah
[Music]
yeah dammit he's bleaching me he's like
Jamie oh no I do I think really killed
it
okay hold on hold on hon its head popped
off I don't know if that means it died
oh yeah I would run and like to the
right try to dodge him because I don't
know if he's dead yet he's very injured
yes
nope oh yeah fire again is he dead no I
would fire he's gonna kill he's gonna
kill my friend oh [ __ ] okay okay you
mean another mall table I feel like he's
almost dead yeah but it's better to use
those and bullets I should have done it
done it while I had the chance
wait I can't why not
[Music]
that now huh I'm tempted to have you
wipe why I did okay you did yeah I guess
so
you use the red and green is the only
thing but yeah you're gonna do you would
have had to go through this all right
yeah you're good that's good I could see
why fire is useful against those I don't
think the handgun rounds would seem like
they were doing I feel like they weren't
doing anything yeah well thanks for the
tip geez someone mentioned that I'll
find it I don't want to get drawn into
counts too much Oh God
oh I know I don't know what to do all
that brought him down to caution are you
kidding shoot it with a handgun I'd say
are you serious yeah or just a boy it's
gonna be hard to avoid it's just a [ __ ]
that Lake that was the thing that had to
happen to me can I step on it no I don't
think so like I lost the whole health my
windows I think every time we record
there's like wine or drinks at CBS now I
know I'm telling you it's so consistent
I've become like I'm just expecting
alcohol when I come here there's another
one
hold on a second if I die will wipe but
I'm gonna go for it yeah I just be
[ __ ] hurling those and then I'm gonna
maybe no no no no off what I don't want
him to die what what do you mean [ __ ]
off like no I was gonna have him like
run away okay but yeah I would just keep
hurling molotovs at it as I only have
two more I have a shotgun out yes want
me to have him shoot in I my options are
he doesn't do [ __ ] maybe haven't run
away for now I have Rebecca throw those
next to if that doesn't do it just have
a shotgun ready Billy you idiot oh [ __ ]
alright okay here here's my we should
wipe we didn't do too much and I and I
got it no we didn't think this through
as enough cuz yeah that's fine don't
worry about it okay
now I got it
[Music]
I think we can do that much much better
because okay this room so they take like
three seconds to transform since this
room is a dead end you're not going to
be coming back here
presumably I think you could rush it
let's see what items are here cuz I
think they're items you could get and
run out before he transforms killed it
though dead yeah cuz I do the whole
thing over again yeah but now we know
like I can think I really think that
ammo and health is worth saving that we
just used on him
well that health that we'll use in the
future he just dreamed I know it's
annoying but I think in the long run
it's better mmm so I'm just gonna quit
and restart it's not very cool not very
Resident Evil uh I'll do it but yes it
is we're being we're being stingy with
items and what is that
it's a McDonald's commercial where
they're eating chicken McNuggets and
he's like girl don't be stingy yes in
dailies michi that that song is actually
super catchy yeah alright so let's talk
about this oh you can see McDonald songs
first of all that song is good I don't
know what you are singing okay so this
will be a quick one because I have them
all tubs necessary and I know where I'm
going and I'm not going to lay around
you definitely wanna go in that first
room and don't trigger the second one in
the hallway so then he won't transform
until you come back out and even then
you don't even have to fight him I'm
pretty sure you can get into the rooms
you need it out and dodge him before
even transforms I just it's you'll be so
much better off if you avoid using stuff
wait what's the plan I'll show you
so the firt the the room you just went
into with the visa handle yeah I don't
have the visa handle you that room you
just run in grab and run out and that
dudes never gonna be a problem again in
trouble okay so you're saying don't
fight him yeah Oh take one character and
leave the other in the hallway got it
because the the Leech in the hallway
does not the one in the hallway what do
you have to kill no you don't so I think
you can even sneak by him because he
takes like three seconds to transform so
as long as you don't walk too far in the
hallway at first he's not gonna but
don't I use that hallway again yeah but
it's like I understand the one with the
handle so I go but I'll never go in
there again but I will go in but I will
go in that hallway several times maybe
got another room in there I know
so we're going upstairs
so in this hallway there's this room
here there's where the guy is that I'm
never gonna go and see again
but then there's two other doors in here
I know but you don't yeah like I'm gonna
have to do that guy I'm saying I think
we could dodge him he's not gonna trip
if you can get into that door on the
right before he even transforms that's
gonna reset his thing when you come back
out we can deal with it but I think you
can get each of the doors are close
enough where you can get from door to
door without him transforming we'll try
it if not yes we'll go your way and go
guns blazing okay I don't think it's the
plan that will get you killed
yeah the most part all right so I'm
gonna give these to her all of them
she's going to give the shotgun shells
to him all of them and this gun and then
he's going to convince these and I quit
and sorry I this actually takes a while
but it's pretty worth it oh wait I just
unequipped this and then he's going to
be set on idle and he's not going to
shoot anyone okay that's it let's go
baby
he's hurt he's hurting he's a hurtin
alright so in here and then in the water
door and then immediately in that room
and then you're saying cuz like here's
the thing I would I'll leave him now
right because I don't wanna like it's
gonna matter it is gonna matter because
I don't want him in the hallway with a
with a person that's what I was trying
to tell you you're not gonna you don't
trigger that bleach until you round that
corner but why have him in there at all
then that's I'm saying it doesn't make a
difference so I'm just gonna leave him
in here okay
I feel safer with him in there okay
she's the one with the multis okay just
don't walk too far ahead just go in
there and then turn left go get the
handle and get out of there get the
handle and get out you're probably
enough to jewbilee he's probably gonna
hit me that's alright alright so now
ready wait is there something here first
I don't remember no well I'm you can go
forward and check he's again there he's
not gonna trigger it yeah just go okay
okay here we go other wall the wall yeah
it's not going well
just get out of here
[ __ ] the camera the camera could not be
a problem anymore just whatever you make
sure you don't trigger this you each
bring Billy in here are you short mm-hmm
why because you both want to go down to
the next room like I think you legit
need I'm putting him on no shooties
though okay great cuz we're not going
for it let's regroup okay right you're
going okay open your map don't it might
have happened no you're fine you would
have heard it go to the door on the
right you're doing that one first
yep bring both of them in there yep
it's not going well
now what if there's one in here kill
anything that's in here got it sweet
fans are so scary Fanning around what's
the saloon the bar it's a piano bar are
you learned nothing from this series
last time she was in a piano room oh my
god she sucks maybe Billy needs to play
I was weird
yeah maybe Billy's better let's plays
Billy
it'll love it down down down down down
town dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
[Music]
he's better than she is apparently Wow
wha
okay I think send Rebecca in there
without him I don't know I mean if
anybody stays out here it's gotta be him
right he's the only one who could play
the piano well enough
well oh hey there anything behind the
bar can you go behind enough on the this
side of it you're just magazines better
than your piano he is good if I don't
see how that bar looks impenetrable all
right unfortunately no so you want me to
leave him I'll go okay I see something
right there hopefully there's not a way
what how many um I have six
but I know there's blood there's that
wine I love that we'll never know
taste it blow our [ __ ] so if there's
something else in here I'm feeling
frisky
it means like you know spicy
assassinated no it doesn't it's like
frisky like Friskies is it cat food
Friskies with my that's right where do
you think they got the name cuz cats are
frisky playful 1/500 yeah I steer
director dick
wait a minute sick mother urban
dictionary although commonly used
sexually frisky can also imply a
lifestyle someone who's frisky is apt to
do anything anyway that's right okay I
stand corrected
there you go oh there's a YouTube
channel called frisky bubbly perky yeah
me in comedy videos see you're learning
okay very playful or lively : sexually
playful or excited but that's like
addition we yeah I know you your
definition pops up before mine that's
gone rule is ground rules dictate that
you were correct wait what's that other
item I'm no don't bring him in here why
I'm telling you keep him out here he's
only I could play piano does she have an
extra space or no oh I see maybe give
him the visa handle
we're gonna do a little exchange because
she's out of spots and now she can go
get it do you want him to have the
handle too yeah oh right I did promise
so Alison Shearer and her husband Sam
are kant's our viewers
so there's coming here and I my
endangered no I should shut Alison I'll
get to in a second don't worry apologies
took me this long in the episode so yeah
Alison Shearer was saying guys can you
do me a huge favor and do a shout out
next episode for my husband Sam hi
literally your biggest fan he's watched
all of your series at least two or three
times now damn we look forward to seeing
you two every week if you could we love
you guys Alison thanks so much for
commenting she's got a photo of dogs I
always forget it that's a dog okay
Alison let me know what kind of dog is
in your profile he's very he or she is
very cute very cute cool it's um think
of it as I'm like going to sleep tonight
that's just something you're gonna think
about her dog no it's like I always
think of the thing that I was supposed
to yeah Boston Terrier no I know what
those look like
but anyway
so he's got the so there's a fourth
there's another door that haven't been
in and it's here yeah I I think you just
want to bring one person that person
beans Billy because he could take more
damage he has a healing item right
here's the red and green still you
haven't used that I have not but you're
saying only take one person yeah why
because a lot of tips that are telling
me that here we go so I'm gonna leave
I'm gonna leave her wait what I am group
he has the visa handle that's good he
has the handle and my dad do we need the
battery me he has the he has the handle
but not the battery he also doesn't have
a lot of like I mean it's not hard and
he's got it now there you go all right
here we go all right I'm gonna come out
of here and I'm just gonna go for the
door yeah go north that was fast
oh you got it nice job
so I have no um maltose it's not big
deal well you know I like nothing okay
that's fine
I sort of accounted for that okay so
we're running up it to a point okay so
there's a right room do not go into the
West room yet and I'm trying okay this
is one of those times where I actually
kind of know what's gonna happen this
room or this room the left the left room
so I'm gonna go to the room I'm looking
at now yeah okay I'm gonna go do it
yes yes and then just remember you can
come back to this hallway so I'm not I'm
never gonna go into that other room no
you are just never never never is what I
got out of that those are the worst kind
you're on the hot seat go how many are
there I hear them
oh no there's a lot can die please be
dead don't get up the other suite nice
crowd control thank you oh no I did I
say visa handled have won like three
times I I totally said visa handling
more once too many times you want to
hear something stupid I did today
another all right let me tell you mine I
went to yoga last night in a Cathedral
in like a church I know it's weird and
it's weird I was praying in a yoga
studio one of the glass stained windows
looks like Colonel Sanders it like
straight up does and I was like not
really thinking and I just like tweeted
it like wow this stained glass window
and a church looks like Colonel Sanders
and I spelled colonel like
colonel of course in a got leg I missed
that tweet I took like five minutes for
like someone to be like you idiot and I
was like I'm such an idiot and I delete
it I deleted I was so embarrassed
because like I know better but like I
can't take this
and it's shotgun probably also like
insulted some towns like patron saint
can you listen to me I can't take these
shotgun shells because I took the
[ __ ] battery unless I can get rid of
the battery
I shouldn't have taken this battery okay
here's the thing okay shotgun shells a
valuable switch to Rebecca don't come in
here you don't need we're back in here
yeah go through back through the water
motif door to the creek yeah just dodge
that dude get her in there wife just to
get her out of there in general okay
but you want her in here outside of the
water door yeah this should actually
wait so I so that's my mouth oh sorry
sorry sorry a crucial piece of
information would be whether if say
Rebecca goes south in that hallway and
he follows her will he just
automatically come back to where he
started or where he actually be lured
toward that direction to make it easier
for Billy to come through I think he
would follow me okay so that in that
case yeah by I would take take her
you need to unload items with Billy for
sure right but I can't I know as I'm
saying so you need to bring him back
here too but I'm thinking that her going
back there first will lure it but he can
go to this room with her maybe without
getting hit and then just give her the
battery yeah but then he's got to go
back in that door increasing his chance
it's like tenfold that he's gonna get a
little nip I think you're just safer and
yeah I think you're more likely to avoid
a nip if you if you ghosts go south of
the Rebecca right now rather than to
have them both coming from the same door
okay and it'll also be a useful
experiment to know that for the future
okay
that keyhole is shaped like a key that
doesn't make sense you see that
[Music]
sorry I had to make a new plan damn it
how her damn I don't let it get to you
it's fine
people there's probably a small set of
people who are gonna hate me for not
killing this guy yeah I know I still
think it's worth it you're getting a lot
of ammo
they tried dodging dodge huge I don't
know I mean I've already gone this far
they Minds will exchange the goods so
that he can [ __ ] get the thing you
know what you call it all right
she's feeling frisky as you say yeah all
right so I got both of them so the
options are I either just continuously
throw fire on that idiot he's full but
she know they're both false that's it
but he has health and he's on orange
caution so if he takes anything he needs
to have that full heal what's gonna
happen I don't know you could kill that
thing that like changes the whole point
of what we do yeah it does I said I say
I think you could still dodge it so
there's something I know that could [ __ ]
you over that I don't want to share too
much and like but I in this room yeah
kind of so can I save no it's not in
that room it's once you go into that
room and then come back out a new leech
will be in that hallway like he'll spawn
behind you so you don't want to go in
there until you're ready to you probably
should only bring one person
are we doing that this episode right
yeah it's not we're doing it now yeah
well there's a lot of items in there
what's in this room
a lot of items [ __ ] and I'm full so I
should kill this thing because we're
gonna come back and forth I was just
trying to dodge it so you don't have to
waste it I have to okay that's fine
but like you said it defeats the purpose
of dodging in the first place yes you
have to live with that for the rest of
your life don't put that [ __ ] on me I am
so I you could still dodge it just oh
man I'm I'm getting in this wolf no I'm
patient Mike now I'm patient I'm nice
and I'm generous and I'm warm you're not
you can't fool anyone everyone knows who
you are all right I'm going to god I
really don't want to die I'm gonna go
with him okay and I'm in a malt of the
[ __ ] out of that thing because he has a
full heal okay
god I'm like afraid I'm gonna go into
this hallway and kill it first then I'm
gonna heal just with him
yeah and then I'm gonna go into here
like if anything I would say bring both
of them so like why she can't you can
kill it before yes before it grabs him
and hurts it I'll go alone
what like it's not gonna be right on you
immediately it's gonna be close but like
if you have two people shooting at a
could prevent him from touching you at
all if I throw a Molotov on it can I
dodge it I don't think it's do that I
don't think has a lot of like knock back
I I see your line thinking I don't want
her getting hurt she's gonna get hurt
okay it's fine I got it I'm gonna take
at this point I trust your judgment I
don't want to die
I'm like really stressed out because I
like God bless it all right let me just
think about this if he's like on my butt
when I come through this door we're
gonna have a problem I'm hoping like I
have a little bit of room yeah I'm
always bad I would like one
I need like a little bit of room and if
this happen all right didn't work out
it's not working out I'm gonna die
don't die yeah just play your track
nice
you ready thanks that's it this job that
could have gone way worse say I still
yeah that was my mom I still don't think
it was a waste to dodge in the beginning
because you could have been hurt way
more he did get into a fight I'm not
gonna stress about that part because I
have to stress about what's about to
happen to me right now no no you're in a
very good situation bring them both like
the way I don't want her to come no no
no no you there's a lot of items next
room you guys she's full I know that's
I'm saying bring both of them back to
the main hall unload some [ __ ] and then
come back with
that's I thought we were on the same
page with that well I was just gonna say
I was gonna go into that room kill this
thing no no it's not in that room it's
gonna be in this hallway you're in right
now I mean I'll just do it right now and
get it over well you don't need to but
I'm in the zone you don't need to kill
it you can dodge it you saw you could
dodge them this way okay
I cleared out that thingy for you I'm
saying like bring back the items to the
grenade launcher the main hall unload
some [ __ ] you can leave her there and
then come back I feel like I'm really
lucky that I didn't die just that wait I
don't think so I think you use skill to
dodge around the corner and line up the
Molotov itas Ron you idiot gross another
one I can get one want me to you can
either go back those noises always
noises SCANA body I mean I could just
leave them here like is there value and
like going all the way in the main hall
I just have items are in one place
because Wilson remember that guy was
saying just put them in the thingy and
that's up the stairs okay you come here
definitely worth saving after you go to
this oh my god absolutely wait I thought
this is almost the end of the episode I
think time is 15 minutes
this room safe right believe so now what
this don't oh no this doors yeah yeah
you're safe but this is this isn't a
water most people put three emblems you
need crickets my least favorite insects
all right so my leaving I'm like right
here yeah also do me a favor can you
check that door I think that's the three
emblem door what door there's no keyhole
or maybe the emblem thing is down there
you know I'm talking about like the
three emblems you're with all the
doodads oh yeah they're right there oh
you couldn't unload them right now two
of them she I only have one I think the
one you have you can at least put that
in there save five seconds the three
fundamental pillars of business there
are five types of businesses practice
railroads patience Mercury hospitals
uh-huh food services and hotels uh-huh
what am I doing with this and
electricians what am i doing this
battery and home service uh I don't know
what the batteries dropping in here I
guess okay all you want to make sure is
that you go back oh my suggestion is to
go back with Billy with no weapon to
save room for six items well she has
four are you saying I'm only gonna bring
one person yeah one person that's what I
was trying to do what I suggested going
with one person for like an hour but no
um defenses to the GU
yeah so you're saying we're not gonna
fight it we're gonna go in that room
maybe load up and then Julie is like run
yeah all right that's a look it can be
done all right so that's what we're
doing
it's Dane that's not what I intended to
do that counts as one of my swaps and I
didn't even do a good job maybe bring
Molotov to them but then I can't do all
six items I don't I don't know that
specifically six I just think it's a lot
it'd be funny if it was six I love how
like if they were real people in like
real life he's like putting down his gun
he's just got like three wines it's a
very good image all right so let's do
this all right so I'm leaving her like
Billy's just gonna handle this correct
what a man I remember batteries for the
elevator out front of the house
I remember that the outdoor area we'll
have to do that next episode yeah cuz
this is the this is the finale huh I'm
glad we killed this thing in the hallway
like I don't I forgot no jus keep movin
keep movin what are you doing
I don't want her in this oh yeah don't
bring her I didn't even know he had her
uh yeah leave her here I don't want her
getting leached up I'll check it out
Roger to stay here just carrying these
three wine bottles
go baby go
yeah that would have exploded his hand a
long time ago I think I think maybe it's
like an oil lantern where it's not like
it ever explodes unless you chuck it
honestly it's really simple weapon but
whoever thought of the Molotov cocktail
Andre Molotov all right so hopefully it
freaks out here oh yeah so it's back
it's in the back I'm giving you too many
things so yeah you're fine you can take
your time until you come back
Wow as very very rushed named VHS love
the estrus love Molotov during World War
two I mean it's pretty innovative you
must admit I'd love to throw a Molotov
at something I'm getting kind of full
here
he's in a roomful of
good good game design they make you come
go out of your way like to risk going
this room and something happening and
this dude spawns and you got a lot of
items but you got dodging oh yeah risk
reward
I like that noise it looks like I think
I did it unless I'm missing anything
open your inventory really quick I
acquired spray a red and green bullets
more wine empty bottle yeah that's good
that's it okay so I'm gonna try to not
use this and just run yeah you don't
need to you should be able to go baby go
[Music]
just let's sweet so two tablets that was
a good episode do want me to put the
other tablet over yet ten minutes
well I just don't want to die okay yeah
no it's probably good time see if we can
make it a shorter like I I would be if
you want cuz like I'm down with that
what I'm saying is no [ __ ] I forgot to
get the girl I'm happy to get the other
tablet and put the tablet cuz like I
don't wanna have to deal with that later
like that point cuz you're gonna be
transferring items as our friend fancies
yeah I mean like I can do that like
let's do that I just don't want to do
something let's recruit Roger I don't
want to do something that's gonna cause
me to lose 40 minutes of progress it's
my fear oh yeah say for sure well I
don't want to say twice in like an
episode you guys say it's not a big deal
but I don't like it Oh save after you do
the games yeah yeah sure that's what I
was agreeing with sorry okay we're on
the same page we're all on the trolley
here so there's no save in this circle
that's like my only issue with this plan
of like dropping off all the goo here
which I'm gonna do because what are you
keep saying goo just let my stuff my goo
my crap
do you call stuffing my garb you know
dr. Phil Angie said I like these Knievel
episodes were Mike and Mary both sloshed
well you're in luck
I tend to do that a lot Mohammed our
friend Mohammed Agati said Wow didn't
think my earlier tip tip for the tip-off
for the grenade launcher will make you
that paranoid all episode I know it did
it did I tried calming Mary downs it not
work
would have been funny through going up
against the hunters with a handgun booth
we have been really funny though going
up against the hunters the handgun
thanks for the shoutout
Mary and happy birthday Mike Thank You
Muhammad ah next time I come over you
guys need to somehow squeeze me in an
episode oh yeah we've been talking about
like very good night like I mean
obviously this room is done here we've
got a whole studio here can you spot if
you watched our other shows you probably
recognize like the desk but it's just a
matter of figuring out when do you is
that in the area tonight back dead air
wow that's a deep cut from mister we
really enjoyed doing that show together
I don't think it ever like blew up but I
think it was one of the funnest parts of
my week I enjoyed talking about scary
stuff it was just something that we
liked to do I think dead air is kind of
this now cuz we talked about like that
kind of stuff for all I'm gonna go see
Mandy I swear it it's pretty good I
don't want to know anything about it
because people keep like kind of there's
been like some kind of like spoiler es
things that I've seen so I'm trying to
not look anymore yeah Jake Decker at
GameSpot and I well he's like a big big
Nicolas Cage fan yeah I respect Nicolas
Cage a ton but Jake likes him a lot
we're gonna try to see it but the only
jig stand is limited release right now a
lot of people
so it we it's like only playing at noon
every day so can you take this
boxer boxer boxer ooh 13 said great any
Mary needs to work on her gym looks
directly into the camera face plenty of
practice to be had with Mike's comedy
quote unquote yeah when did they have a
fight during Resident Evil 5 I don't
know what episode it was but Mary was
playing terribly and I have there's a
very particular episode where it's
obvious we're not play fighting like I'm
like mad at him because you're like
traditionally like snarky and quippy
with me but like for whatever reason I
think if I got I got cookie at you and
you got mad and we're like I'm not gonna
play anymore and you put down your
controller and there was a boss and we
were like subject to lose a lot of
[ __ ] work and I was like put up your
pick up your controller and you were
like no and it was just like we [ __ ]
win at it because I was like this
[ __ ] it was we had words yeah but I
think we got over it really quickly I
don't think I talk to you for a week I'm
just kidding yeah that is how this works
yeah so a few people said don't like
guess might make it crowded I agree we
wouldn't it would only be like certain
occasion be a lot cuz I I feel the same
way like I wouldn't want to deal with
that all the time yeah I don't like the
only with you as alright I was joking
actually let me Howie yeah right in
first season he talks to me
[Music]
all right this room is full five what
happened so would it have been trying to
tell by the thumbnails your partner died
yeah we were really really all right we
got to I just forgot guy makes you have
to it went all the way down the ladder
for nothing I found the moment where he
dropped me on the drawbridge and I was
legitimately a that was funny too
there's like a famous moment where
you're like do not drop me and I wasn't
like I didn't intend to but as so many
things happen you know like I dropped
the bridge it was a genuine mistake but
I don't think that you were interested
in what I had to say sucks I can't leave
the extending on here should I combine
some plants cuz she's a plant combiner
why don't we I'm sorry why do we have
Barry Burton on whatever yeah you might
as well I guess she's good at it [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] I think I said this last week put
that hundred episode montage that meri
made is up on our YouTube channel I need
to like heaven so just to clarify it was
during the boss fight with my mom if
someone can find it actually the super
help folks I can't find it right now
and then there's more herbs in that lab
is this a safe space to you think like
this open area this area right yeah it's
safe this is like a relatively safe area
right yeah yeah we're getting stuff done
we're getting it done axela it's the
boss fight when Excel uh mutates and you
have to use the you have to press the
button and wait for the rocket launch or
the flamethrower to come down and Mary
was being really stubborn oh my god if
you watch it you can decide for
yourselves who's being the bigger piece
I'm confident that if the world rewatch
is that they will know they'll know to
clarify I don't even want to rewatch it
I bet you don't as I know I can I like
got the gas to make more multi got those
bottles and I forgot to get the bottles
so I'll have to do that next episode but
that's okay we're doing a good spot all
right I'm gonna save
I could make the mall Taub's that's like
something I could do
yeah oh right now you know I'm doing it
right now I feel the thing is about this
game and I like this game very much
but I'll tell you like the organizing
and the like [ __ ] I'm full you take them
all Tom's is not my favorite thing to do
with my time
and I would say like as a resident evil
space the way you organize and utilize
your space is important it's imperative
to the game play so I like that but I
like it in the horror sense where it's
like I don't have enough room kind of
like actually what happened to this
episode where we're like I don't have
enough room I either have to take no
weapons to like get all this stuff and
that's scary and I think it's it's
really it's enjoyable it's like an
enjoyable thing to do I like it less I
don't want to examine this I like it
less when it's just like alright she's
gotta take this cuz she's got a deal
with the thing and it's like it's not as
fun but it doesn't mean that this game
isn't fun I would like to say for the
record that I think this game is really
enjoyable it's just that the constant
use of like it's tedious it's tedious
[ __ ] stupid bottles and fuel combined
come in you don't have bottles I just
did it
oh sweet where have you been I thought
you you've been examining safe box while
she's been hanging out I did examine
several pucks so I will accept that
nasty retort but ciao
do you wake you did you get those giving
ribbons with her back up I do sweet
casually walks down with his wide
shoulders and his moltov cocktail yeah
that's what you should go to Halloween
--is a lit Molotov cocktail and uh so
you get get handcuffs get a beater get
jeans and I will paint mother love on
your arm on your glass you unfortunately
have already work says no you wish I'll
consider it and I'll go in daisy dukes
yeah you could the dicks all right I
feel like we've accomplished a lot I
feel good about this episode we
restarted once but only because we could
do it more efficiently which I do
believe we did with it
all right it has been done sweet good
job everyone
sweet yeah that's it we'll be back next
Saturday will mark an evil don't rush me
off this time you take so much time no I
did well I'm just trying to thank our
loyal viewers sorry
sounds like she hates you guys just
kidding yeah we'll be back next Saturday
it's pretty much it I'd say no really
news to convey okay do you have anything
you want to say any big announcements
Saturday probably gonna take my dog
[Music]